[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal d'information
nous sommes le mardi 8 novembre et parmi
elles les sujets que nous allons aborder
dans l'actualité blinoise le leader
français de l'optique krys group vient
d'inaugurer l'extension de son site de
production de verre à bazens ville à ce
jour huit millions d'euros sur les 12
prévus ont été investis à la fraternité
au coeur du concours organisé par
youtube la plateforme de vidéos en ligne
proposait aux jeunes d'évoquer la
thématique en moins de 90 secondes des
classes de trappes étaient en
compétition pour la finale et puis le
bureau de poste de plaisir gare ferme
ses portes incompréhension des riverains
qui se mobilisent une pétition circule
actuelle
et pour ouvrir cette édition cette
information donnée par nos confrères du
figaro encouragé par le tour européen à
le groupe chinois h anna a décidé de
s'associer à l'open de france de golf
dès 2017 sa dotation passera à 7
millions d'euros un intérêt motivés ont
sans doute par la position qu'occupe
aujourd'hui la france sur l'échiquier
mondial du golf avec l'organisation de
la prochaine édition de la ryder cup
prévu justement au golf national en
septembre 2018 l'ancien partenaire
historique de la compétition alstom
avait décidé de ne plus supporter
sponsors autre changement la promotion
de l'open sera assurée par l'european
tour en remplacement du groupe amaury
sport
économie à la société et crise qui
renforce donc son implantation en france
je vous le disais en titre
l'inauguration de l'extension du site de
production de verre à bazens vl se
tenait ce matin même en présence de
représentants du gouvernement pour le
groupe c'est donc l'occasion de
renforcer sa communication autour du
made in france camille lambert et
anne-laure l'anguille
il aura fallu trois ans pour mener à
terme ses travaux le groupe chris leader
de l'optique en france a inauguré ses
nouveaux locaux une opération conduite
entre 2014 et 2016 avec pour objectif de
moderniser sa production et augmenter sa
capacité nous pouvions fabriquer jusqu'à
présent union 258 vers nous pourrons
maintenant on fabrique un million cinq
cent mille par an
deuxième chose nous avons modernisé la
totalité la quasi totalité de nos
machines pour gagner en productivité
comme une grande partie de ce que nous
vendons nos magasins et fabriqués dans
nos usines fallait que nous augmentions
la capacité de cette usine martine
pinville la secrétaire d'état chargé du
commerce de l'artisanat étaient
présentes pour l'inauguration
grâce à cet investissement la société
veut atteindre les 10 millions
d'articles vendus un moyen de faire
rayonner le territoire pour cette
entreprise porteuse du label origine
france garantie ce plan d'investissement
qui se chiffre à 12 millions d'euros
c'est accompagné de l'embauchent 60
personnes supplémentaires ce qui est
important c'est d'avoir une usine en
france ça c'est un choix stratégique
nous a semblé important
de fabriquer nos verts en france de
revendiquer que nous les fabriquons en
france d'ailleurs dans les estampillé
origine france garantie puisque nos
clients ils sont sensibles avec
l'embauché cette nouvelle équipe la
capacité de production a grimpé de 20%
sur la période de 2014 2016 pour 2017 le
groupe prévoit aussi d'améliorer la
technologie de sévères 100% devraient
être équipés de traitement anti-rayures
emploi et cette semaine des métiers de
la finance lancé par l'agglomération de
saint quentin et sa cité des métiers
management mission de contrôle fonctions
support des postes sont à pourvoir pour
vous aider à en décrocher un plusieurs
rendez vous sont proposés depuis lundi
on notera notamment jeudi 10 novembre de
9h30 à 12h30 un job dating en présence
des sociétés axa de la caisse d'epargne
encore de la bnp écoutez la directrice
de la cité des métiers c'est au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est vraiment de s'informer sur la
réalité d'un métier quand on veut
s'orienter ou quand on est en
reconversion professionnelle l'idée
c'est de partir de soi et d'explorer les
différentes possibilités les différents
métiers qui peuvent convenir de faire
voilà des recherches documentaires et
ensuite de rencontrer des professionnels
pour se rapprocher le plus possible de
cette réalité c'est dans cet esprit là
et aussi pour mettre en valeur les
métiers qui sont sur le territoire une
autre feu informations concernant
justement l'emploi et la formation
l'estac à l'école d'ingénieurs basée à
saint quentin en yvelines et sncf
mobilité on désire ont signé une
convention de partenariat afin de
développer de nouveaux axes de
collaboration un
partenariat qui prévoit notamment de
développer les échanges entre les
étudiants les jeunes diplômés les
anciens élèves ingénieurs le corps
professoral également de l'estaca et le
département de recrutement hays les
managers et les collaborateurs de la
sncf pour sncf mobilité cela permettra
également d'identifier et des candidats
ayant bénéficié du savoir faire de l
estaca pour ses futurs recrutements nous
parlons de fraternité à présent avec
cette initiative de youtube le site
d'hébergement de vidéos vient de
proposer aux jeunes de mettre en scène
en 90 secondes ce grand principe de la
république à travers son opération toi
même tu filmes après plusieurs mois de
travail le verdict est tombé et c'était
dans les locaux de google france à paris
en présence de la ministre de
l'éducation et d'un jury composé
notamment de jamel debbouze on notera
parmi les finalistes elle la présencede
yvelinois de trappistes même le
reportage de mélanie poquet camille
lambert et nicolas landry ils ont foulé
le tapis rouge ces jeunes trappistes
faisait partie des finalistes du
concours toi même tu filmes initiée par
youtube avec l'or de vidéos ils ont
voulu parler des personnes homosexuelles
et de la ville de trappes les
homosexuels sont reste des personnes
normales
ils sont comme nous tu ce qu'ils aiment
les garçons ils aiment les filles quoi
dans notre entourage je pense à tout
certaines personnes et aussi que quand
c'est pas facile d'en parler et on a
voulu toucher certaines personnes dans
notre film à venir
les préjugés sur la ville de trappes et
tout ce que les médias en fait 10 sur la
ville de trappes 90 secondes pour
s'exprimer autour de la fraternité avait
plusieurs mois de travail l'issue a eu
lieu hier avec la remise des prix par le
jury composé notamment du trappistes
jamel debbouze un dernier
est quelque chose qu'on ne peut
expliquer
suivre un dernier des
centres internes it et cette année les
jeunes de trappes repartent bredouilles
mantes-la-jolie obtient deux prix dont
celui de la jeunesse commis par la
ministre de l'éducation najat vallaud
belkacem
on entre là réfléchi pendant très
longtemps pour l'histoire
mr travail
mérite bien et on est content on est
content j'étais très très content de
pouvoir gagner ce prix pour moi c'est
énorme en fait et moi je pensais pas que
j'allais gagner un prix parce qu'elle
avait d'autres vidéos qui était vraiment
bien et le concours sera à nouveau
organisé l'an prochain les trappistes
veulent y participer cette année 800
jeunes ont goûté à la réalisation
nous partons pour maurepas à présent où
des dizaines de migrants installés
depuis vendredi dans la salle des fêtes
ont reçu la visite de benoît un mois
hier le député socialiste de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines est venu
rencontrer notamment les membres de
l'association aurore en charge de leur
accueil on les écoute à ce propos
et ce qui est formidable c'est de voir
l'hospitalité qui est celle des français
à travers ces bénévoles associatifs qui
ont fait appel à d'autres bénévoles de
l'association trappe action solidaire de
trappes le secours catholique de
montigny-le-bretonneux des gens qui se
font un aimant sont venus à mener des
vêtements des chaussures de quoi voilà
finalement réconforter des hommes
isolé sur leurs familles
souvent condamnés à l'exil en raison des
violences dans leur pays je trouve que
quand il ya des démarches généreuse de
français faut les montrer parce qu'on
pense aujourd'hui à montrer ce qui va
pas
social toujours avec elle la poste qui
poursuit sa réorganisation c'est
aujourd'hui un bureau qui ferme ses
portes à plaisir la cgt évoque une
pétition signée par plus de 2000
personnes et organise régulièrement des
rassemblements sur place les précisions
de nicolas kirillovitch et de patrick
jacques de dixmude
leur message est sans équivoque
syndicalistes et riverains du quartier
de la gare de plaisir disent non à la
fermeture de la poste annexe acté il y a
trois jours cette fermeture était prévue
depuis plusieurs semaines problème de
rentabilité selon la poste en argument
que réfute la cgt
la poste c'est un service public ça doit
permette l'accès équitable de tous les
usagers à ce service donc il faut des
bureaux de proximité et les la stratégie
les choix ne doivent pas être fait
uniquement en tout cas non il doit pas
du tout est fait ça des critères de
rentabilité
mise en cause également pour avoir donné
son accord la mairie se défend et met en
avant un service plus performant et
mieux adapté le nouveau bureau de poste
relais sera notamment ouvert sept jours
sur sept
et
demi journée
d'apporter ce jour aucun par contre la
proposition qui était fait et de saint
phalle et supermarchés pas oubli y est
plus centrale et avec une amplitude
horaire équivalent aux horaires
supermarché
la nouvelle poste relais situé dans le
centre commercial brigitte est ouverte
du lundi au samedi entre 8h30 et 20h30
et le dimanche entre 9h et 13h
pour terminer ce journal et à la proche
des longues soirées d'hiver retour sur
le festival du jeu de société de ville
pour les visiteurs s'y sont rendus le
week-end dernier dans l'espoir de
trouver de nouvelles idées pour mettre à
profit leurs dimanches en famille
reportages préparés par anne laure
l'anguille sur des images de nicolas
landry
ils étaient près de 3000 à participer au
festival du jeu de villepreux le
week-end dernier enfin participer est un
faible mot les uns se sont battus avec
vigueur d'autres ont beaucoup réfléchi
et certains ont même voyager lassé des
objectifs at-elle c'est d'aller gong art
à une autre d'une ville d'une ville à
une autre ville en europe jeu de rôle de
plateau figurines jeux vidéo animation
combat il y en avait pour tous les goûts
et l'entrée du festival était gratuite
villepreux a lancé la manifestation l'an
dernier suite au succès des soirées jeux
de sa médiathèque on se rend compte que
de plus en plus les gens ont besoin de
de s'amuser de sortir pas forcément très
loin de chez eux à des coûts réduits
jouer c'est en fait l'un des trucs qui
plaît le plus au cerveau et tous les
gens qui viennent ici même ceux qui
disent qu'ils savaient qu'ils n'aiment
pas jouer trouve en fait matière à
réflexion et à rencontre ici tous les
univers coexistent de star wars au
monstre médiévaux il n'y a qu'un pas les
esprits et roanne avec as abstenus on
est dans un univers médiéval fantastique
où différents peuples s'affrontent pour
accomplir des missions divers et variés
donc préétabli avant la partie
villepreux devrait reconduire le
festival l'an prochain vous l'aurez
compris pour s'échapper de son quotidien
rien de tel qu'un bon jeu de société
merci de nous avoir suivis prochain
journal mercredi aux mêmes horaires
replay de nos reportages et de nos
émissions sur notre site internet et en
attendant les programmes se poursuivre
sur notre antenne
[Musique]